hey everyone carolyn pettit here i'm
joined by Peter Brown Peter you got back
from Japan recently where you spent some
time playing metal gear solid 5 ground
zero yeah that is super rad and our
readers have some specials for you about
that experience cool now I'm hoping that
I can get this information out of you
without making you endure a metal gear
solid like portrait sequence good luck
our first question comes from foreigner
ISM who asks what will keep me coming
back to this game with such a short
campaign I'm glad you asked like a lot
of people I assumed getting into this
game that it was going to be just a few
hours long Kojima said this an open
world game that isn't terribly accurate
it's more of an open format level you
have the option to play out these
missions in a lot of different ways on
top of that there are also tries to meet
such as you know spotting every guard
and marking him on your little handheld
device as quickly as possible and every
ranking that you achieve in a B C or D
you unlock new items that you can use in
future missions as well so it basically
the game just keeps opening up different
ways to explore it our next question
comes from evil demon 00 who asks his
ground zeroes have a small open world or
can you only play missions within
boundaries yes it's a small open world
in that it's not a linear like path that
you follow and there are boundaries that
if you try to exit what's called Camp
Omega the military base in the game the
game will say hey you're gonna quit this
mission you want to go back to the main
menu yeah yeah you say no no i don't i
thought i could go it's small their
boundaries but it's not as linear as a
lot of metal gear expiry next step is
macias 1236 who asks what new feature in
Metal Gear Solid 5 did you like the most
really what it is it's how open every
mission is say finding a truck planting
c4 on that truck getting in the back of
it letting it take you to a location you
get off to find a vantage point where
you can keep an eye on that truck
watching it as it goes into a part of
the base that's away from your objective
and then you blow up the sea for
everyone goes over there and runs you go
to the other path you don't have to do
it that way you can sneak in and choke
everyone out you can interrogate knock
people out hide their bodies i mean this
my favorite feature is just how open the
entire experiences our next question
comes from oddly 07 who asks is metal
gear solid 5 the perfect entry in the
series for someone who has never played
in
your style game in the past no I think
really long story short the smartest way
to enter the series is either with snake
eater which is the first game in the
entire timeline or with peace walker
which is the game just before the start
of ground zeroes and you can play that
in the Legacy Collection now on the 360
or ps3 or in the HD flex from the same
symptoms enemies close by alright next
we have paradigm fallen who wants to
know will we see any sort of demo or
limited version of metal gear online
within ground zeroes no that does not
seem to be the case I played what is
essentially the final build of the game
there was nothing like that in there and
our last question comes to us from KH m
83 who asks how long game duration is
and when phantom pain will probably be
released I think I know what you're
asking there is one main mission in the
game for submissions and then a fifth
unlockable mission that requires you to
collect items in order to get it the
ground zeroes has some story and you
will experience that story by going from
point A to point B but there is so much
more to explore within and it's not just
choking or shooting a guard I mean you
can manipulate the entire base you know
I at your will you have a lot of tools
that you won't find unless you run
around and search every corner that's
available to you so I played the game
for about 8 8 to 9 hours and I got
thirty percent of everything completed
in terms of the phantom pain coming out
they say right now late 2015 I question
that Kojima has also said that vacuum
will be hundreds of times larger than
ground zeroes given how dense and
complex and highly orchestrated the base
is in ground zeroes are then to
replicate that 50 times let alone 100 in
that span of time I think is going is a
very ambitious bet but the official word
is still late 2015 so metal gear solid 5
ground zeroes actually comes out really
soon yes mart 18th less than two weeks
from today alright so people can come
back to gamespot for your review and
plenty of other content on metal gear
solid 5 ground zeroes thanks for
watching
you